wir wollen jetzt hier im studio noch
etwas mehr über diesen fall sprechen der
noch immer viele offene fragen
beinhaltet deswegen bei uns jetzt am
markt hoffmann hoffmann man hat noch
immer viele offen fragen ist gerade
gesagt hat zum einen wie der
tatverdächtige überhaupt eine kleine im
iran gekommen ist warum er sie dann ins
wasser geworfen hat wenn sie diese
ersten erkenntnisse gerade sehen wie die
polizei hat was was machen sie als
diesem fall ja dieser fall ist erst mal
nicht die regel sondern ganz deutlich
eine ausnahme von der regel denn im
grunde weg jahr ein fall wie dieser eine
absolute urangst aller eltern ein kind
am nikolaus morgen aus einem gut
behüteten elternhaus haushalt
verschwindet am helllichten tag am
morgen am nikolaustag im schlafanzug und
wird aus der eigenen wohnung entführt
ich glaube ich muss da mal die angst der
eltern ein klein bisschen nehmen denn
solche fälle sind extrem selten wer
macht so was die ware aber etwas
erleichtern die antwort ist eigentlich
niemand das ist weder typisch für
einzelne sexualstraftäter noch ist es
typisch für menschenhandel oder
organisierte kriminalität ich habe
gestern zufälligerweise in bezug auf
diesen fall bei facebook eine meldung
gesehen die sinngemäß lautete eltern
haltet eure kinder fest es verschwinden
tausende kinder jedes jahr spurlos
allein 2018 sollen zwölf 1791 kinder
spurlos verschwunden sein
ich habe die zahl mal mit den daten von
bka abgeglichen und tatsächlich stimmt
es zwölf 1791 kinder wurden vermisst
gemeldet was man aber dazu sagen müsste
damit die meldung vollständig ist ist
das 12 1604 auch wieder aufgetaucht sind
das ist eine aufklärungsquote von
ungefähr 98 5 prozent und bei den
anderen liegt auch nicht unbedingt eine
straftat voraus heißt das passiert dass
kinder vermisst gemeldet werden und dann
innerhalb von 24 stunden wieder
auftauchen dass sich nur um ein
missverständnis handelt das passiert
häufig das wirklich eine straftat
vorliegt und ein dritter also jemand
außerhalb der familie der täter ist es
passiert extrem selten aber hier scheint
tatsächlich hier teile ich die
auffassung der staatsanwaltschaft dass
hier ein solcher fall vorliegt
lassen sie uns einmal reingehen weil
hier ist ja nun genau das passiert wenn
sie sich das angucken spricht das dafür
dass der täter das womöglich in der
vergangenheit schon mal versucht hat und
vor allem die noch wichtigere frage wird
das noch mal versuchen ja über den
mutmasslichen täter kann man anhand der
infos die bislang bekannt sind nicht so
viel sagen aber man kann ganz sicher
sagen dass die umgebung aus der das
mädchen mutmasslich entführt wurde ist
ja eine extrem sichere umgebung das
eigene elternhaus am nikolaus morgen das
was aus sicht des opfers des mädchens
eine sichere wohlbehütete umgebung ist
ist ja aus perspektive der täter
eigentlich der worst case aus sicht der
täter ist nur absolute hochrisiko
umgebung
wann immer täter das gilt für
verschiedene delikte in einem solchen
hochrisiko bereich gehen und irgendwas
tun wo man sagt das ist eigentlich
unmöglich dass das kann man überhaupt
nicht schaffen egal ob bei einbrüchen
bei raub oder auch bei entführungen man
immer täter in diesen hochrisiko bereich
gehen trifft meist eins von beiden zu
entweder es ist extrem gut geplant
übertage observiert wahnsinn installiert
wusste genau was das zeitfenster von
vier sekunden ist man das mädchen allein
ist um in die wohnung zu kommen das
mädchen zu entführen wieder rauszukommen
oder zweite möglichkeit es ist gar nicht
geplant
und das trifft meistens eher zu oftmals
sind es dann täter die entweder
psychisch krank sind oder auch drogen
oder alkoholeinfluss spielt eine rolle
manchmal sind sie schlicht
desorganisiert und das ist alles nicht
so geplant wie man sich das vorstellt
und wenn man sich den weiteren
tatverlauf was bisher bekanntes anschaut
mit einem mädchen im schlafanzug
bekleidet kilometer durch die innenstadt
zu laufen
das ist nicht besonders clever vorbei an
kameras mit einem blau-gelben
auffälligen schal und roten hahn also
insgesamt spricht dass er für kein
planvolles vorgehen und auch das motiv
ist vollkommen unklar das mädchen
entführen durch die stadt laufen dann
ins wasser laufen was war hier
eigentlich das ziel geht es um sexuellen
missbrauch sollte es darum gehen
lösegeld zu erpressen oder ist es ein
versuchtes tötungsdelikt denn das muss
man ganz klar sagen wer ein
sechsjähriges mädchen bei diesen
temperaturen wassertemperatur ungefähr
4,5 grad ins wasser wirft nimmt den tod
in kauf wenn es nicht sogar das ziel war
das sind es da einmal ganz kurz rein
gehen warum glauben sie hat er das kind
ins wasser geworfen was was kann ein
motiv dafür seien überhaupt keine ahnung
war ja auch noch gar nicht bekannt ist
wer der täter eigentlich ist wichtig ist
jetzt erstmal den täter zu
identifizieren und dann stellt sich
natürlich die frage was das motiv war
und ob die person überhaupt schuldfähig
war
oftmals stellt sich aber gerade in
solchen chaotisch erscheinenden fällen
heraus dass die täter eben auch entweder
nicht schuldfähig waren oder unter
drogen alkoholeinfluss standen und dann
erübrigt sich ein bisschen die frage
nach der logik denn wenn man mit logik
probiert dinge zu erklären die nicht
logisch entschieden wurden macht das
eigentlich keinen sinn und das halte ich
hier keineswegs für ausgeschlossen aber
da muss man der polizei natürlich noch
ein bisschen zeit geben das zu ermitteln
und jetzt sind erstmals zeugen gefragt
diesen mann auch zu identifizieren aber
ich denke da stehen die chancen ziemlich
gut eine frage die ich mir auch gestellt
habe weil sie immer wieder auch gesagt
haben das elternhaus da weiß das kind
natürlich das essen sicher ortes wie
hoch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
kleine kinder auch mit gehen mit fremden
leuten wie einfach kann man kinder dazu
bewegen gibt es da irgendwelche
statistiken zu wie oft das passiert dass
kinder von ganz alleine
erst damit geht man sie also gar nicht
verschleppen muss in dem moment so zu
sein
das hängt stark davon ab wie viel
prävention gemacht wird und inwiefern
kindern das auch beigebracht würde ich
erinnere mich gut als kind bereits ein
buch gelesen oder vorgelesen bekommen zu
haben gehen niemals mit einem fremden
mit und ich glaube dass es noch immer
üblich dass eltern die ihre kinder auch
sensibilisieren und dann ist es sehr
unwahrscheinlich wenn kinder aber etwas
naiver sind oder es häufiger vorkommen
dass vielleicht beide eltern berufstätig
sind und öfter freunde oder fremde das
kind abholen
dann kann es natürlich um einiges
einfacher sein genaue zahlen sind hier
ganz schwer zu benennen denn erst mal
ist die frage was zählt man eigentlich
als kindesentführung zählen auch
versuchte taten dazu und ganz häufig ist
es so dass man eigentlich eher von einer
kindesentziehung sprechen muss das
bedeutet eltern die sich geschieden
haben sorgerechtsstreit und dann
entführt ein elternteil das kind ich
will das nicht schönreden oder gut reden
aber es ist etwas anderes als das was
sich menschen typischerweise wenn sie
hören 300 entführungen in diesem
zeitraum dann dann stellen sich menschen
etwas anderes darunter vor als ein
sorgerechtsstreit bei dem ein elternteil
das kind entführt denn diese fälle enden
natürlich meistens nicht tödlich die
letzte frage noch wir haben es gehört
das gab überwachungskameras offenbar
liegen der polizei ja bilder von ihm vor
da sind hinweise eingegangen was glauben
sie wie lange dauert es bis der fall
aufgeklärt ist kann man der hoffnung
haben
das hängt davon ab wie clever er sich
jetzt im nachhinein
verhält aber mehr würde ich dazu nicht
sagen weil noch laufen natürlich die
ermittlungen und die staatsanwaltschaft
hält sich auch aus taktischen gründen
zurück und das würde ich in dem fall
genauso tun denn vielen dank für das
gespräch auf man danke dafür hoffen wir
das ja dieser freiheit aufgelöst wird
dankeschön mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren